Matt R special came out he's getting
killed for his first joke which was I
guess was a domestic violence joke for
the people that were complaining he sent
them a link said this is if you're
complaining here's where you should
leave your complaints and it was a link
for people to buy a special needs helmet
dude his response was perfect
and hilarious if you don't like a joke
just don't watch that comedian yeah that
that's it listen either you laugh at
everything or you laugh at nothing
you're not allowed to pick and
choose just cuz something bothers you
that is not okay I promise you Matt R is
a very respectful young man he's not out
beating people he's not pro- domestic
violence no and that joke is not making
anybody go home and hit their wife you
touchy you don't get to be the
fun police and you don't get to
police what other people think is funny